okay so let's move to the first session
on my right yeah actually I'm the only
person who does the introduction the
rest are so famous and successful they
don't but anyway I'll go ahead and
Martha Lane Fox entrepreneur take
evangelist
she's a crossbencher peer and his
current chief of no she's a chance for
the Open University head of go on which
aims to help millions more people and
organizations get online I recommend her
YouTube video of the excellent Dimbleby
lecture this spring which I think was
one of the best I've seen then run and
Donna my far-right CEO of a telephone
telephone akka UK which is known as o2
who is also on the Guardian Media Group
board and therefore is a prowler violet
Alan's and was on the inside of the
papers business when the Snowden
revelations were taking place my
grateful an Alan Ross Roger editor of
The Guardian until last week and soon to
be or maybe already head of Lady
Margaret Hall he has fought a number of
very famous battles notably on WikiLeaks
and Edward Snowden case obviously most
recently and the paper was under his
editorship awarded the Pulitzer Prize
which is obviously extraordinarily rare
in Britain and Cory Doctorow a brilliant
and articulate science-fiction author
campaigner for freedom on the internet
and co-editor of boy and boy so first
question to you all we're starting in
the beginning well for when did you
first see the web the first time I saw
the Internet I remember very clearly
went beautiful old University got put
into the smallest most modern room at
the top of a building you could ever
imagine it the disappointment but in
walked a guy called Toby who introduced
himself to me and said he just come back
from Japan and he showed me on his small
handheld device what the weather was
doing in Tokyo and what the weather was
doing in San Francisco it seemed
baffling to me and that was the internet
did you did you predict anything when
you saw it did a penny drop I didn't
predict that I would end up working
anywhere near it
I didn't I run what about you so the
first first time I really got close to
the Internet was actually way back when
in all of 2002 and the first ever what
was called a wireless PDA was a thing
called the o2 XDA and was the forerunner
of all of our current smartphones and
actually he was called XDA because it
was the crossover of voice and data for
your digital assistant and this was
before we had a Facebook or Twitter of
MySpace any of these so this was the
first time you could take this away on
mobile and you suddenly started to see
the transformation that now is a lot
more people access the internet on
mobile than they do on fixed 4.2 billion
people around the world which is more
than have access to clean water or a
toothbrush it's amazing I think I know
when Allen did see the internet but
because I was working in New York and
somebody showed it to me
in 92 93 and then I think it was mosaic
or Netscape Navigator and I think I came
back and told you about it and before I
knew what you were on the web and
setting out the Guardian website but
right it was 1993 and I went to America
and found a thing called the Internet
which was a great surprise
I remember going to there was a company
called Knight Ridder that had a lab down
in Boulder Colorado and we went all the
way down to Boulder Colorado and all
they had was a piece of wood about that
size very much like an iPad and they
said one day we will read all our
newspapers on that and I was completely
convinced I didn't worry cuz it was just
a piece of wood but they were weird
obviously been closed down and abolished
long before anybody invented the iPad
but they were strangely right but Corey
you are slightly different from the rest
of us he's only a doctor from the age of
five says my father was a computer
scientist who was doing a degree at the
Ontario Institute of studies in
education in Toronto where there was a
pdp-11
a deck computer and he brought home an
acoustic coupler which is this some it
looks like a sex toy for telephones it
has two suction cup
and you dial up on a rotary dial phone
and you once you hear the scream you put
it and they scream at each other it
didn't have a screen it had a roll of
paper and a daisy wheel printer so you
could only compute until the paper ran
out my mom who was working in an
elementary school used to bring home
rolls a paper towel from the loo so we
get a thousand feet of brown paper towel
and you could compute both sides of it
and then you were done but I would love
to know when I mean I think it for me
the penny did take a long time to drop I
don't about you Martha
whenever with some last-minute
confounded yeah six seven eight I think
after my 1992 that was with my friend
Toby's experience then I ended up quite
by chance working in a company that was
looking at the media and telecom sector
and that was when my very first piece of
work was called what is the internet for
BT in fact you could probably do the
same piece of work now but um that was
when the penny dropped for me because I
suddenly could see it from a completely
different perspective commercial or in
terms of society at that point probably
more I was thinking commercially but
sort of I was a techno you toe peon
probably more then and you know 21 so I
kind of thought the world was always
going to be better in the future and
changed in the most positive and
fabulous ways so it definitely seemed
like a democratic force for good did you
have that Hope runnin that sort of
slightly hippyish feeling of release and
endless possibility I think Martha was
well ahead of a time I mean to put it in
context pipe X provided the first
digital dial-up service in 1992 you know
so if you take 1997-1998 the future may
have been discovered but it wasn't well
distributed at that time and I think
most of us probably saw our first
exposure to the internet actually in an
office environment where some office
connectivity had been provided and it
was more a b2b tool in in some respects
or in education and and academic tool in
those days I think what really and
forgive me I'll go back to the XDA but
when you suddenly realize that actually
you get Encyclopedia Britannica in your
pocket and you can have it with you all
the time
then you start to think about or what if
and and for me certainly what this
revolution is all about is we're
creating an information economy and in
the past information was power this is
democratizing access to information and
we've had an agricultural revolution and
Industrial Revolution and in each case
you have a technology shift followed by
a fundamental behavioral and societal
shift we haven't yet seen in my view the
behavioral and societal shift that will
be occasioned by digital so I think
we're actually on the technology curve
the big change you see yet to come Alan
do you think the internet could have
evolved in any other way than the way we
know it today I think that the big thing
that's changed as it just as a user is
two big things one one is the thing that
Rona was talking about which is the as a
journalist obviously or you're
interesting in the messages you're
sending out but I was always terribly
interested in what the messages would be
that would come back and the web 2.0
when people could talk to each other and
publish and as well those respond to us
was for me almost more important than
the birth of the Internet and I think
Road knows right away we haven't begun
to realize what that means yet does a
user there was a kind of a heady moment
early on when if you put a search term
into Google you've got something back
that wasn't somebody trying to sell you
something and and that was wonderful it
you know for people just interested in
sort of finding things out and now
nearly always any search term is is it's
now part of a commercial world of people
trying to sell you stuff and it would be
wonderful to try and find an alternative
maybe there is one an alternative Google
in which was with more about knowledge
and less about straight commerce Cory
what about you do you think it could
have evolved in
different way and retain some of that
openness and sense of boundless freedom
there well I mean I'm not a historical
determinist so yes of course lots of
different things could have happened I
mean I believe in the adjacent possible
so people have ideas for things like
airplanes at periodic intervals through
the whole of human history but
eventually some of those ideas get
realized because we have material
science and physics to kind of catch up
with it which is what when people say
you get railroads when it's railroading
time they don't mean that there's a
mystical railroading energy in the air
they just mean that we have now attained
the point where when that idea occurs
with its on scheduled regularity that's
some of the people to whom it occurs
will be able to figure out how to make
it a reality so I don't think we run on
Rails I think we have lots of moments in
our history where things have gone well
and some where they've gone poorly when
the World Wide Web Consortium decided
that members who participated in
standard-setting would have to observe
web patents so there would be no toll
gates for producing web technology that
was a key juncture it could have gone a
different way it could have been much
worse but on the other hand when the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act was
passed in 98 and when the European
copyright directive was passed in 2001
both of them produce extraordinarily bad
policy that if we hadn't had it I think
things would be much better they both
provide for among other things an
unaccountable system of arbitrary
censorship and a rule prohibiting
disclosing security vulnerabilities and
technologies that we rely on which could
have produced which which does present a
clear and present danger to us and which
is only going to get worse unless we can
do something about it
data is a big subject isn't it Martha I
wonder you've spoken to your bb lecture
about a sense that was should be a Magna
Carta for the internet which would
presumably involve data but on a broader
sense how much do you think government
should intervene and supervise the big
web companies to try and control them
guard our rights and so forth how do you
think government should be more involved
than it is I think government should do
three things because I would argue that
we're actually having a bit of a crisis
right now you know I just got stuck in
hideous traffic coming across London you
know London has an infrastructure
problem but the web has a much much
bigger Internet sorry has a much much
bigger infrastructure problem if you
like and I think the government should
focus on three things firstly we have
got to improve the state of our digital
infrastructure urgently you know you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
see that South Korea knock it out the
park all the time in terms of the
economy and productivity partly because
they have that superfast infrastructure
that's one big piece of the puzzle and
somewhere that government can be more
aggressive secondly we have an absolute
crisis in gender on the internet massive
huge enormous the percentage of women in
the tech and creative industries I saw a
report just this week have gone down
there are now nearly doubled the
percentage of women in Parliament that
is probably marginally older than the
tech sector double it's a disaster it's
a disaster because power money product
design everything is worse and
imbalanced and asymmetrical so that's
the second thing I think they should
intervene and the third thing isn't it
thank you in a broader a broader skills
crisis which I for a while and no we
still have massive issues with code in
jobs that we need to fill and a massive
issue and broader digital skills let
alone the skills of our establishment
and parliamentarians and they are free
to me very tangible areas that
government could intervene they don't
even have to touch a big tech company to
make a big shift in those areas how do
you you must have a lot to do with
governments really and how do you fight
I mean one of the things that strikes me
about government's most of the people
making decisions are my age and I
absolutely know nothing by the way the
IRC which the intelligence Security
Committee I noted in the last government
we had an average age of 59 and I didn't
think was one member of that committee
that understood the issues what's your
experience of the sort of commercial
where look I think that's entirely right
I think we have to break it into two or
three areas though so I think the
management of critical national
infrastructure needs to be done
holistically digital infrastructure is
an essential ingredient we're happy and
it's not a criticism of a chest
we're happy to spend fifty four billion
pounds on it for a tenth of that you
would transform the digital
infrastructure the good or value-added
product that will be most distributed
around our economy in the next 20 years
is not people going an hour faster to
Manchester it's data and yet we're not
willing to provide the infrastructure
for a second thing I would say is it's
not just about the management of so I
saw John Whittingdale this morning and
talked about how we make sure that we
all have better connectivity but one of
our challenges is and I went to the
common select committee in 2012 to talk
about spectrum and talk about rural
coverage and John and I were admitted on
record that more MPs write to him and me
asking for a mass not to be built in
their local community than asked for a
mast to be built now that has changed
and I think the third thing going back
to the last point that Martha made is
this is not about technology what we
have is we have an analog society and we
have a digital opportunity and we're
singularly failing to match talent to
opportunity in the way we educate and
prepare our young people and it's not
just the education system itself but its
parents is people of my age you have
analog ambitions for the children simply
the jobs that exist today and will for
the next ten years just didn't exist
when those people went to school or went
through university so we have a
fundamental change and it goes back to
my overarching point is the pace of
Technology change has massively
outstripped the pace of societal and
behavioral change that's the crisis not
a technology crisis Allen you've had
slightly more difficult relations with
government over the last three or four
years I wonder I know a lot about it
because herb is you know with you on
much of it but I wonder what you feel
about government's true role I mean the
internet presumably does have to be
policed in some sense but I wonder if
you and then Cory could comment on the
exact the limits to that sort of
supervision well I think there's been a
missing stage in the debate so we seem
to be operating on the basis that the
digital world operates two completely
different rules from the pre-digital
world and that just seems odd to me so
as an example over
centuries various groups and
organizations institutions professions
have built up conventions about what is
confidential doctors priests MPs lawyers
journalists they are they all for good
reasons believe that their conversations
with their sources their clients their
patients their constituents are
confidential and that's been built up
over two or three hundred years and
somebody this year in the home office
decided that actually that no longer
counted and that the police on the
sanction of the Home Office would no
longer respect any forms of privilege
that seems to be such a fundamental
thing in which is just somebody saying
well this new world because we can do
this we can abolish this we're going to
give ourselves the power to do that and
that in the year in which we celebrate
Magna Carta is such a profound change
and I just wonder why nobody thinks even
to discuss it why do we assume that the
new world is going to be different from
the old world and that digital is
somehow this magical word which
completely alters the relationship
between government and citizen Cory you
are you a very impassioned telephone
call the other day with me and Hanna
intelligence where you were talking
about how we can own the future still
it's not all negative and and and I
certainly believe that but would you
enlarge on that sure you know I'm a a
lot of talks about the future of
technology and the present day of
technology and what I think we should do
and at the end somebody always puts
their hand up and says are you
optimistic and you know on a science
fiction writer and so I understand that
predicting the future is a mug's game
science fiction writers are terrible at
it and science fiction writers who try
are like drug dealers who sample their
own product it never goes well but
besides that optimism and pessimism are
largely irrelevant to what we should do
I mean if you are convinced that in the
future the internet was going to go from
being the nervous
of the 21st century into being the
world's most perfect and enduring
surveillance apparatus that will harden
our power relationships in ways that
will deny opportunities to everyone save
the tiny elites who are currently on top
you would get up every morning and get
out of bed and do everything you could
to change that fact and if you were
convinced that the internet wouldn't do
that you would get up every morning and
get out of bed and do everything you
could to ensure that fact right so it
doesn't change your course of action
whether you're optimistic or pessimistic
so rather than optimism or pessimism I'm
a great fan of hope hope is the idea
that the future is up for grabs that
what we do today changes what happens
tomorrow hope is why if your ship sinks
in the middle of the sea you tread water
not because most people whose ship sinks
get picked up but because everyone who's
been picked up treaded water until
rescue arrived it's a necessary but
insufficient precondition for a better
world and if you were along with someone
else who couldn't kick for themselves
you put their arms around your neck and
you would kick for them because that's
what we do when we have hope we'd gives
us the strength to carry along the
people around us and people who know and
care about this stuff maybe in a
minority today we have not reached peak
surveillance by any means but we reach
peak indifference to surveillance there
will never be a moment at which fewer
people are concerned about these issues
than today and so those people will
start kicking with us if we keep if we
keep at it if we keep them afloat until
the time arrives so I do think that the
future is ours to influence if not to
determine and that when things look
worst that's the moment at which you can
least afford to give up the last thing
we you know we have to rush through this
afternoon there are lots of things I'd
like to ask the panel I would love to
hear from the next hour and a half but
we can't I'd like to ask them what is
the single pleasure the quintessential
pleasure for them of using the web
Ronen first I have a 21 year old
daughter who's at University in
Australia and I get to be with her
through the internet by using FaceTime
or Skype that's the best thing for me
what
I walk with a stick I can honestly say
I'd have no clothes no food I'd be
completely disorganized if it wasn't for
the internet because it enables you to
be at much more peak physical capacity
than you actually are it's quite
profoundly personal in that way for me
the thing I don't like is when I
announce something at dinner or my
children or my wife fat checks be
immediate that I hate well I love that
because I have this I have a a terrible
memory
I'm just a terrible memory and if you've
got a phone in your pocket you don't
need a memory and Google is a sort of
hard drive that I carry around with me
and all the problems I had of not being
able to learn dates or kings and queens
of England
I'm now super smart because I have it
all there or actually even about
wearables apparently paid people who
were given an intelligence test
knowledge test those that remembered
from their brains and those who use
Google and the people who use Google
thought they were more intelligent than
the people who remembered simply using
their brain which is interesting how
quickly we verbs or this Corey what's
your great pleasure so I love this
business of having an outboard brain you
know I just as having a calculator
liberate you from being a shitty human
spreadsheet and allows you to do real
maths having the Internet liberate you
from being a shitty human encyclopedia
and allows you to do real synthetic
thought every interesting thing that
crosses my transom and there's an
seemingly infinite number of them I turn
into a post that explains to strangers
why it's interesting this is powerfully
Nimonic it joins this kind of super
dense cloud of fragmentary ideas that
kind of knock around in my subconscious
and eventually two of them glom together
and nucleate and turn into novels or
speeches or essays it's it's wonderful
to not have to bother yourself with the
minutiae and be able to look at bigger
more synthetic questions
that's terrific way to end
and typically articulate well Thank You
panel thank you very much for a
brilliant first session i'm keeping
their time in the schedule so and we're
all going to go off and be replaced by
somebody else but thank you very much